okay everybody knows you as Winston from
Ghostbusters yes so you and Howard have
this connection to Ivan Reitman Ivan was
the producer on Howard's movies private
parts first let me say Ivan was really
really a brilliant man and um I have so
much just love and appreciation for him
this Ghostbusters mean to you what we
think it means to you well I don't know
what you think it means but uh like the
biggest role of your life you know no no
no no none of that they were doing
Ghostbusters and the movie was being
made by a lot of people who were really
successful Bill Murray Dan Aykroyd
Harold Ramis you know they had already
made a number of movies and I was the
guy who was brought in
um and so finding my place in the middle
of that and they were all welcoming
um you know and inclusive the studio
wasn't
and the studio continued not to be
so it made it very very difficult
because I was a part of but then very um
selectively I was sort of pushed aside
you know when the posters came out I'm
not on the poster when right just it
took a long time I went to the 30th
Anniversary release of the movie and I
was invited to a theater in Chicago to
introduce a movie and I get there and
all the posters are three guys and I'm
like oh wait a minute you know now I
know the fans see it differently and I'm
so thankful for the fans because the
fans have basically identified with
Winston you know especially young you
know I don't say minority kids but but a
lot of kids you know whatever you know
so it took a long time for the studio
and even now you know we're negotiating
a new movie
um that's uh gearing up to start
shooting in March and uh and I'm like
guys
um you know you know this is there's a
place that I I'm not an add-on and
um and so if I'm gonna do it it has to
make sense you know yeah when you start
out in the business I was always told
it's almost impossible to succeed but if
you get in a major movie from a major
studio and it comes out and it opens
number one it'll change your career well
Ghostbusters didn't do any of that for
me you know I was working pretty
non-stop I did Ghostbusters and it was
two and a half years before I I got
another another movie so
um but it was an important movie a big
movie and I'm so thankful to be a part
of the franchise but it wasn't an easy
Road in fact Ghostbusters I would say it
was probably the most difficult
movie I ever did just from the
psychological
perspective yeah you know everything you
were dealing with the original script
Winston was in the very beginning of the
movie by the time we got ready to shoot
the movie Winston came in halfway
through the movie so it was like all
those things it felt deliberate right
well yeah it definitely felt deliberate
and I'm still not trying to take it
personal because you know I'm sure you
know
um anything bad if you're
African-American and in this country
anything bad happens to you you can
always blame it on because oh because
I'm black but it happens you know I mean
you cut in front of me because I'm so
you don't want to go there that's the
last thing you wanted but sometimes you
just know sometimes you can't explain it
I tell them I tell people all the time
I'm like even if I can't explain it to
you I just know it's because I'm black
yeah I just know yeah yeah and I'm like
wait and when it shows up
um wait a minute I'm getting this
and it's not because come on yeah so I
got nothing bad to say about anybody but
it was hard and it was hard for a long
time it took me probably 10 20 well 10
years anyway to finally get sort of
passed that and just embrace the movie
and enjoy the movie it was it was very
hard Ghostbusters was really hard to
make p to to make peace with